Kim jue a was first introduced to the
world accompanying her father Kim
Jong-un at a missile launch last
November but it was this appearance at a
military parade in Pyongyang last week
that has further fueled speculation
about her being groomed as a future
leader
Kim's beloved daughter says the
commentator
who later describes her as the respected
daughter unusual perhaps in such a
patriarchal society ju a is the second
female to be linked to power
Kim jong-un's sister yo Jong came to
prominence during the summit diplomacy
of recent years tipped as a possible
successor in the event of her brother's
Demise by introducing his daughter now
analysts say Kim could be trying to
avoid his own experience of having power
thrust upon him when the health of his
father Kim Jong-il suddenly declined
after 2008 Kim Jong-un had to learn how
to lead state affairs very quickly and
went through a difficult period building
his power base
this week the birth date of Kim Jong-il
is being marked just one of many
anniversaries in a national calendar
dominated by the one Kim family such a
hereditary hierarchy now three
generations old and seemingly preparing
for a force is unheard of in the
Communist world but it came into being
more by chance than by Design North
Korea's founder Kim il-sung came to
power after World War II as one of a
group of leaders that he had to sweep
away to ultimately establish the Kim
family Dynasty
unlike other socialist systems after
removing his opponents there was no
Force to stop this hereditary succession
the physical likeness of the current
leader to the young Kimmel sung is said
to have cemented the grandson's hold on
power just as the similarity with his
daughter now seemingly helps confirm her
position as Heir Apparent
Robert bride Al Jazeera Seoul